What up yo? This week we flowin
with our boy with Mark Twain’s Adventures
of Huckleberry Finn.
Huck Finn and his main man Tom
Sawyer sittin FAT after their last adventure,
but nxow Huck gotta live with some crusty
ol widow who tryin to “civilize” him.
When Huck’s boozed-up daddy Pap swangs in
to town, he snatches up Huck to live in his
stuffy-ass digs and try to swipe all his cheddar.
Sick of gettin his ass whooped erry time Pap
sips too much crunk juice,
Huck decide to fake his own murder and lay
low on Jackson’s Island while the laws patrollin.
After chillin a couple days on the
island, Huck hooks up with Jim, a slave he
know from the hood, who dun split after hearin
his ass bout to get sold. Since they both
duckin the 5-0, they decide to team up and
skip town.
When our boys get separated, Huck finds himself
at the phat crib of
the Grangerfords, a family who been beefin
wit another crew called the Shepherdsons fo
generations. Deez fools can’t even remember
why they’re bustin caps in eachother. Huck
straight flips when his boy Buck Grangerford
get iced over some bullsh**.
Then Huck and Jim rescue two shady
thugs named the Duke and King as they runnin
from the fuzz.
These fools sliding from town to
town straight hustlin homies fo their paper.
Eventually, these shysters get REAL dirty
and sell Jim to a bunch of plantation owning
crackas named The Phelps.
Huck slides over to da Phelps spot
to free Jim when a woman say “Yo wassap
Tom!?” Tom? Turns out, these cats are Tom
Sawyer’s aunt and uncle and they think Huck
is Tom. When Tom actually shows up, Tom tells
Huck to play it cool and Tom pretends to be
his kid brutha Sid.
Tom comes up with a plan to bust
him out like it some kind of prison break.
But just as they bout to split, Tom gets capped
in the leg and Jim gets GOT again.
Next morning, Tom all like: “Look,
brah. Jim was actually a free man this whole
time. So that escape plan? I was just playin.”
The hell?! A brother’s freedom ain’t no
game.
So Huck and Jim part ways and Tom’s aunt
offers to adopt Huck. but Huck
done with all this “sivil” nonsense, so
he decide to start trekkin to some new turf.
Open up yo ears and get ready for
some truth, son! By far da most throwed-up
symbol up in here is the Mississippi river.
See, the river representin’ freedom-
not only Jim’s freedom from slavery, but
freedom from all the crooked sh** always goin
down in the “civilized” world.
But at the same time, the river
also reppin’ destiny. Cuz it’s the river
doin all the shot calling: where they goin,
when they gonna get there, and what kind of
jacked up sh** they gonna find along the way.
Now even though Huck thinks all dat mess is
whack, it ain’t no thang to
all dem “civilized” peeps Huck dealin
with. And as the only brutha who keepin it
real enough to see through society’s bullsh**-
he gets mad lonely.
Sparky reads quote: “When it was dark I
set by my camp fire smoking, and feeling pretty
satisfied; but by and by it got sort of lonesome,
and so I went and set on the bank and listened
to the currents washing along, and counted
the stars and drift-logs and rafts that come
down” (51)
Only when Huck gets to know Jim
does he find someone he can chill with. And
to Jim, ain’t nobody ever had his back like
Huck. Dat raft becomes the realest home Huck
ever known.
Cuz when he on the shore, Huck
seein stupid sh** go down on the reg- hoods
talkin bout glockin eachother, families icing
kids for no good reason, and his own daddy
slappin him up. On the real, people people
can be dicks, man.
And what’s mad ironic is dat even though
Huck ain’t educated, don’t
buy in to no religious jive, and don’t consider
himself to be “civilized,” he the only
cat who wise to all the backwards-ass nonsense
of a culture that accepts all this- and worst
of all: slavery.
So when Tom’s aunt offers Huck a
place to crash fo good, he says “naw shawty.
I’m straight.” Huck don’t wanna be a
part of the “civilized” world. He’d
rather take his chances and slide to a new
spot where he can create a better one.
And the first step to making it a
better world is by hitting subscribe. Peace,
my well-read ballas.